c'est une nouvelle dont il se serait
bien passé alors qu'il comptait sur les
vacances de la toussaint pour relancer
l'attractivité de la cité royale de
loches ce responsable va devoir composer
avec des mesures sanitaires plus
strictes comme une baisse de la capacité
d'accueil on va adapter notamment les
jauges à l'intérieur de deux monuments
en fonction que des exigences la
situation notamment pour les visites
guidées destinées au jeune public aux
familles on va également mettre en place
un nombre maximum de participants en
fonction de ce que nous impose la
situation serre et les lions ours voire
même dragon des symboles de la royauté
sur lesquels le château a misé pour
attirer petits et grands mais dès ce
samedi
les visites de groupes seront limitées à
10 personnes contre 15 auparavant
on préfère privilégier les enfants pour
les vacances scolaires et il sera
demandé dès la réservation puisque ce
sera sur réservation uniquement qu'un
seul départ ont un seul accompagnant
adultes viennent avec son ou ses enfants
pour laisser le plus de place possible
aux enfants et petit jeu très amusant et
notamment ici avec un soufflé on peut
faire des cris d'animaux
alors il faut se laver les mains avant
de manipuler
voilà donc il ya le gel ici un geste
barrière pas toujours évident à faire
appliquer aux enfants c'est comme à
l'école mais chez vous mais suffisant
pour rassurer les parents et les
encourager à revenir si tout est mis en
oeuvre pour garantir la sécurité de
chacun et les mesures sanitaires
pourquoi pas
le château espère faire le plein de
touristes des places sont disponibles
pour les visites de groupes les mardis
jeudis et dimanches jusqu'à la fin des
vacances de la toussaint